oh hi
oh hey I'm here in town in real real
life normally I'm just a AI rendering
that uh we claim to Avatar say lives in
Texas but the truth is that I only
appear when they allow me to appear and
I've been allowed out of the closet we
ran out of uh AI yeah
in the prop closet so you know you know
how there's like dust them off well what
Wonder Dynamics has like credits or they
did
yeah it's like you know you get you get
credits so that well we ran out and when
we run out then I get to come out you
have to come back in person to renew
those credits right so anyways welcome
back to the corner digital podcast
episode
178 dang how many of those are how many
of these are we gonna do
I was gonna say 533 000. this is the
first podcast I've done quite some time
too it is Ren what have you been up to
man people the people have missed you
well I mean I've either been busy or
I've been hurt right which yeah I don't
want to sound like a broken record so we
don't need to talk about how I'm hurt
well you yeah any new injuries though
just to clear the record make sure
everyone's cool
no no no no they have no new injuries
not at all nope not me the reflection in
your voice what have you learned about
crashing so much though Ren are you
going to change your ways absolutely
okay are you absolutely I'm gonna not
crash as much
that's not an answer
I mean yeah uh okay for those of you who
don't know I recently like uh six seven
weeks ago broke my collarbone again but
it was the other time this side race the
other side this time racing yeah I was
because it's like for the first time
ever I found myself actually getting
really good at a sport like an athletic
sport uh I was I was I've been saying
I'm arguably in the top 25 but
definitely in the top 50 of like the
hundreds of thousands of one-wheelers
out there and you know hundreds of
people are going to these events and I'm
doing really well but sporting this is
this is this is my harsh take on this
sporting like that is a young man's game
well okay which is exactly we're not
spring chickens anymore Ren which is why
I gave myself this year this was the
last year I gave myself to really make a
push because there's a bunch of new
young kids coming in to adulthood who
are aging up into these uh the
pro-mensors like 18 year olds that are
way more limber that can just fall off
and get up the tendons are so flexible
they are it's true it's I mean that's
what that when you're yeah the annoying
uh question I get is like you should
learn how to how to roll and I'm like oh
boy I know how to roll but like the the
time it took for me to hit the bump and
to go down was like I there would
there's zero time to react yeah zero
time it was just like it was going I was
going fast I was cooking down this trail
and I hit like this washboard thing and
it stopped my board dead it was
literally just like right and I was on
the ground I immediately bounced up
by bounce I mean like I jumped up uh got
up off the ground and that was kind of
when I registered like oh my
collarbone's shifting around
it's broken again yeah I was I was
Furious it was hard it's hard to
describe the type of emotions that I was
having at that time because it was
mostly just pure rage and fury and
myself
and the situation it sucked uh but yeah
I mean you're not Tom Brady you know no
I wouldn't I can't keep going at it 45
years old but it was mostly just
disappointment because it immediately
shot my whole my whole season like my
season was shot because of that and I
know I'm not gonna get another shot at
it
that's that's so disappointing they're
right no that's that's right
your own one-wheeling league
so I'm like I'm soft retiring right now
but I'm not gonna I'm not gonna keep
going hard like I have been that's kind
of how the most
that's the most common story when you're
talking about an athletic career ending
though yeah absolutely it's like
something happened toward my ACL and
then and then that was your last chance
and then you it's almost no one gets the
oh and then we won the Super Bowl
it does happen it's like nobody it's
like dude uh it does happen but I'm
saying like you think about all the
people that play a sport or even like
amateur participate in a sport not as a
professional but like when do you stop
doing that sport
that's how I'll tell you dad because
that's the nature that's the nature of
sports competition uh Jamal Murray I
think is his name I just won the NBA
Championship after tearing his ACL a
couple years ago well right but like is
he gonna retire this year now oh no
exactly what a championship right
exactly because you never you're like
well I just won one why would I just why
wouldn't I stop that's what I'm saying
you keep going the irony of it all is
because I recognized at the end of last
year that oh I need to actually start
getting more fit in order to prevent
injury so like in December literally
like the last day of December I sprained
my ankle pretty badly and I was out for
pretty much the first month of this year
and I was like that's no good so I've
been getting really into training I have
a personal trainer I work out twice
twice a week with uh getting really into
yoga and all that stuff and all of that
under the pretense of getting more
athletic and injury prevention it's just
ironic a little bit because the injury I
got I couldn't have prevented I had all
of my protective gear on a full face
helmet full chest pad uh chest plate
shoulder pads double pads shoulder pads
it was the full thing it's like a motor
motorcycle vest that goes down to your
wrists like elbow pads it sounds like
they need to attitude pauldrons to that
there's just no way to protect your
collarbone that way I know I'm just
kidding okay you need one of those
inflatable emergency like suits that
just like as soon as you pull the rip
cord it just
stay positive I thought that could make
like a great like video like
I think there was a company in in
Amsterdam a while ago that made like a
similar inflatable bike helmet to
protect Riders next because it's such a
bicycle like Centric City and like lots
of people wear helmets but I could be
getting this totally wrong let me know
in the comments but like it was a thing
that had a motion detector in like at a
certain threshold it would just
instantly inflate this like neck brace
it's legit I've seen videos
oh sorry yeah
like I saw a thing it was like
motorcycle guys if you like fall off
your bike it freaking just like
it's hard to find the line between like
an airbag which is so explosive it'll
break your neck and something that is
too slow to actually protect you so we
got to really do the math before we make
Emmett put it on but look
Emma is our new intern I just want to
say like there this is not an uncommon
thing that you went through
like a good friend of mine uh who is
like he got his name's Bodie uh number
two uh racer last year you got silver
medal of all of One Wheeling last year
he broke his collarbone three weeks
before I did
doing the same thing on a racetrack but
at a certain point you you have to go I
need to stop this and I'm glad that you
he's also 10 years younger right and I'm
glad that you uh decided to
strengthen your body in order to prevent
injury because the one thing that you
lose
as you get older is muscle mass
once you're over the age of like 30
you're early to mid 30s your muscle mass
if you don't maintain it starts to that
that the older you get the more
dramatically that that declines yeah
um whereas when you're younger it's
cardio is a harder thing to to get and
and maintain but as you get older so
it's flexibility and muscle mass I used
to be able to do the splits as a kid
like to the side yeah you were a splits
kid you had the big curly hair oh yeah
but flexibility and you said you were
doing yoga yeah right flexibility is is
super important to injury prevention
because most of the time when you injure
yourself it's because something is
moving in a way that it's not used to
yeah and the more range of motion you
have with your entire body the less
likely you are to get injured it's I
mean it sounds simple but it's that's
the I rolled my ankle over the weekend
and normally that would have been a
sprained ankle but I just stood up and
was like that was nothing yes I went
down a a half pipe on uh or not a half
pipe a quarter pipe it was only like a
three foot quarter pipe
um in cowboy boots the other day on a
skateboard or just like jumping off a
skateboard that was exactly how I
sprained my ankle in December by the way
it was going down a quarter pipe okay
yeah and I fell off and I sprained my
wrist oh dang okay and it was it's still
not quite perfect and that happened in
November oh last year yeah perhaps
they're sending it though I don't know
I'm fine all right fine fine
send it
um but yeah that's uh you know and now I
go do I yeah no I I every possible
emotion I could have possibly had over
the last two months I've experienced
really yeah it was it wasn't a really
good time for me I'll put it that way
I've definitely rethought my life quite
a bit and so in this thinking process
where did you where did you land on the
sport of one Wheeling run oh I mean I'm
never gonna stop you can't I was I
literally did yeah I did a 24 Mile ride
down a mountain on Sunday why
we we descended 6200 feet vertical
altitude it was amazing it was awesome
steep drop dude yeah it was a bit it was
a big job but like I was I was going
easy you took Dean too didn't you yeah
my sweet Dean he's gonna pound dog pound
the bones of my sweet Dean
how could you do this to me oh don't go
up on the mountain you'll crush your
bones out
it was a good ride it was a casual ride
I'm just uh and I it's it's what I enjoy
most in life there's nothing I enjoy
more than just being on a trail riding
my heart out it's the best man and like
but once you're up there you understand
yeah I get that part of it I get that
part of it but do you always have to go
for finding the line of
you the edge of you know your current
abilities at that time on the machine
that's a good question and no I'm
actively trying to not do that okay this
is good this is good the problem is that
my abilities are so much higher than
everyone I know you know that they just
think I'm always sending it no I'm I'm
playing kind of I'm kind of playing but
like because like I'll do something that
doesn't seem that big of a deal to me
but everyone's like oh my God and I'm
like well I mean
so that everyone I know that I look up
two and one willing this what I just did
would be simple for them the Hell's
Angels do this okay they they ride on
the edge of what a man can ride a
motorcycle on motorcycles they do this
intense much higher Stakes are they yeah
because your magnetic energy
yeah
power versus 20 miles an hour
right it's a very big difference that's
a huge difference especially when you
got giant multi-ton vehicles around you
at various okay here's an interesting
fact that that we found out from
motorcycling that I want I'm wondering
if you should consider this with one
with one Wheeling
most people who fall off a motorcycle
and die it's the propensity for how um
how How likely you are to die if you
fall off your bike grows
exponentially with age
because your body falls and sustains a
similar injury when you're a young man
does not recover when you fall and
sustain the injuries when you're an
older man that's fair but no matter what
you're eating [__] right so do you
knowing that
do you have are you like hey you know
what I'm gonna do I'm gonna Coast
into my middle ages on my one wheel
rather than Speed Ahead on the edge of
of all potential reality I'm gonna Coast
I mean I I'm still probably gonna try to
push it here and there but that that's
what I I mean by I was giving myself
this year to really try to try to hone
this ability to be as fast and as good
as possible to be competitive at the
sport that is quickly growing and it's a
sport that I adore and love uh but now
that I've kind of just lost the wave
like my racing didn't work out I missed
the race the first race straight just
didn't get there in time and then the
second race I just broke my collarbone
and just like okay I'm out for the rest
of the season and
so now because of that I'm not even
going to really try to race anymore I
don't think but
I mean I still think there's a ton of
value in being a proponent of the sport
and the I would love to keep like
commentating races that there's like you
know there's a ton of that I think it
brings a ton of joy to people like any
sport but I just yeah no I mean I just
don't want to see you breaking all your
bones again man because when you get
when you when you hit like your mid-40s
dude you're gonna start to feel this
[__] I'm telling you I I uh okay all
right so I'm just trying to like
mitigate it a little bit because I want
to see you upright that's all no and I I
I appreciate the concern and I think
it's valid you know it's it's just one
of those things where it's like
uh there's you are who you are
yeah right uh one one question but it is
specifically why I'm never going to own
a motorcycle because I am accident prone
enough that I just do not trust myself
with one yeah
that's valid we're gonna ask uh with you
taking a step back from uh the
competitive racing circuit do you have
any interest in like um fingerboards
look out for no that wasn't my question
all you have to look up in in there is
Carpal tunnel uh but uh do you have any
interest in in focusing more on like
um filming video parts and like pushing
like the progression of like trick
riding because I saw the video You Did
in the mini ramp and I don't know I
don't know if that's that's uh something
you're more interested in I've always
been more of a Trail Rider than a trick
writer like the guys I know who do
tricks I'm nowhere remotely near their
level even though I can do a fair number
of them so I that's even further out for
me than racing so tricks are more
dangerous even though they're kind of
more in my opinion they're it's hard to
say rather
most people who do tricks on a one wheel
will say tricks aren't that dangerous
because they know how to like not roll
their ankle when they fall down or not
hit their head and stuff like that and
yet a lot of the times they still do
that and I don't know I'm I can I can
the tricks that I can do I'm happy with
but I'm not trying to push the edge of
that here's a question I don't enjoy it
about the progression of one whale
tricking have they begun to modify the
boards at all to have less weight and
probably less battery capacity so that
they can do more with the boards yeah
there's a there's a battery pack from
tri-battery systems called the the stunt
pack it's a half battery pack that you
actually it only fills half of the the
the the enclosure yeah and you put it
closer to the wheel so you get a smaller
moment of a nurse or less weight yeah
for the XR there's no batteries for the
GT right now it's all locked down system
dude put that in the V1 I have a super
light board dude the V1 is still by far
the lightest board it's also the weakest
board and a crunchy experience I can't
believe it yeah it was very touchy
remember that works upstairs
no I don't need to be reminded of how
touchy it is
back in the day
and being like Oh your foot's off
didn't even know that my foot was like
why is my my foot's in the same spot it
was in two minutes ago shuts off yeah
why is it off just cuz just because just
you know be ready to fall you're
grateful for every second that you're on
that board when you're on it really you
really don't take it for granted because
as soon as you do you're you're on the
ground yeah I will say almost every time
this is the first time I got injured in
a serious way where I wasn't
not paying full attention
does that does that make sense like
every time I've gotten injured in the
past it was because I wasn't paying 100
attention to like what was in front of
me like I looked away or I got
sidetracked by something and I didn't
really see that's probably why it was
the most frustrating for you because you
were doing everything you could and it
still brought you down and and broke a
bone which is incredibly frustrating did
I show you the I just got my photos this
morning of the the surgery so I actually
see what the titanium plate looks like
on actual like broken bone with my skin
pulled apart
so how long do they have to leave that
in there it's there forever forever I
could elect to have it taken out in like
a year but it's another invasive surgery
I mean the the crazy thing I didn't
expect going into this was that I I the
nerve damage I cannot feel any of my
skin from my shoulder to my sternum oh I
don't know if you can if you can see the
scar here but like everything underneath
that Scar the Nur uh most of the nerves
there were cut and so I just like can't
do anything so I kind of want to get
like a tattoo yeah exactly I want to get
a tattoo here I don't know what to get
what happens when you go leave a comment
down below suggesting what sort of uh
tattoo I should get across my my yeah
collarbone here let's get let's get like
a nerve a nerve synaptic nerves covering
all the area that you can't feel it's
just a big black patch
I can the swelling has gone down enough
that I can start to feel the screws on
the plate which is kind of bizarre is
the plate rounded or is it flat they
didn't like sand them out they're just
like sharpless I can show you the photo
if you want to see it sure I'll check
out the photo yeah well it's not it's
it's it's a plate that's been like
conformed to the shape of a collarbone
that's pretty dope
um
yeah well desensitized anyway
I feel like I know you very well now
I've literally seen inside of your meat
you have what's the yellow the yellow
that's uh oh that's uh that's like a
sheet of plastic or something oh okay
because my head is kind of yellow when
they chop into it that's why I thought
it doesn't like fat the fat layer like a
little bit dude that's some high-tech
metal in there yeah it's crazy it's like
straight up just Torx heads on these
screws I'm not gonna show you because
it's like legit gruesome but I mean yeah
it's clean though it's not like gruesome
like it's
brutally cut like it's a clean cut well
the other one you can actually see
yeah
I'm sorry for everyone watching and
listening I'm not showing you my broken
here's a quick look broken oh man but
yeah like you can see like the batteries
so these are photos from Ren's surgery
and I asked the surgeon to take photos
during the surgery it's a good good
surgery right there you know yeah I'm
I'm healing if you guys have kids if you
guys have kids like those images will
not be like
because you'll just be like ah you know
another I just yeah another thing
another part of the human body that I
now have a completely different
appreciation for
oh man so I I suggest we move on from
talking about this because this is now
like becoming a series of videos where I
just talk about my injuries on this
series of videos
yes I think it turned into a really good
video here's how we're being taken over
by the corporates guys
it's all going great freaking a here's
some contexts we we thought about this
we've thought about this concept for
months and we were like hey you know
it'd be a good concept we do visual
effects of the universal logo over Earth
and we actually figure out like what it
would do if something of that size and
scale and mass appeared over the surface
of the Earth and so we sat on this we
thought about it we found a window to
make it
you went out and did all the math with
Nick you guys spent three weeks like you
know freaking everything from the
initial conceptualization to then the
math to the filming and then the visual
effects and boom and then we drop it on
Sunday it's doing great Griffin does um
I usually downplay stuff but like I look
at that and I'm like yeah it's a banger
thumb that was the first thumbnail that
someone reached out to me looking for
the credit for that thumbnail right yeah
and it was like right who made this
thumbnail I must know I was like credit
Griffin no it's it's like hey if
if this image looks like fun you're
gonna like this video also like a fun
fact about how we filmed that thumbnail
like so I'm like flying up in the air in
it but all we did for that is basically
I stood right outside these uh glass
doors right here with Griffin uh looking
down on me from above on the mezzanine
and I just kind of like did a jump and
like kicked my feedback scorpion style
looking up at him with my arm out we did
a few versions of that and you kind of
like Photoshop mashed a couple of them
together it's like one of those wedding
photos where the photographer goes okay
groomsmen everyone's gonna jump at the
same time and then you all jump with the
Bridesmaids together and it's like
exactly hey but except it was we blasted
light from the other end of the studio
to make it look like I was top lit from
the Sun
this guy's married
this guy is married and as kids
so so the video goes live
and it got a copyright strike it's going
great everything
was trending it was going great
everyone's working one of ten too right
and and then who comes out of the ten
who comes in these videos with their big
swinging dongs and their armies of
lawyers
Universal Studios and they go guys we're
going to claim this entire video we're
going to claim monetization on this
entire video
because
from
minute Mark 3 30 to minute Mark 348
you quietly use the universal theme song
in the background to show off your own
shot of how the logo goes over the earth
now
I get that that's an important part of
the video right the universal logo was
real but our but what are we doing for
you and how are we recontextualizing
your logo in a way that is Artistic
original and wholly transformative
we thought we made a whole video about
it yeah and now we did a test upload we
tested whether or not it would be you
know copyright strike on it and there
wasn't so like okay this will be fine
until it got views now it got views
right and then they so here's the way
that this works and uh this is a little
I might get a little salty here but so
you know what it's just salt is salt is
the flavor of life so here here's the
thing
these companies and I experienced this
when I went through law school what
they'll do is you know you have a big IP
related company like Universal or even
more like product companies like 3M or
you know some of these other companies
they will they will actively hire
new attorneys
usually between like first year out to
like five years out and then they'll
have you know their attorney overlords
who are their the you know the guys who
are further up in The Firm okay and
they'll basically be like oh yeah 3M you
know is one of our clients and uh so
what you got to do is uh you know every
time you see like anyone using the
letter three or the letter M next to the
number three uh you just basically you
just sue them
and uh so yeah America yeah so if you if
you ever see anybody you know like
online and they say oh you know we we
made the universal logo real you just
put a copyright claim right on that
video you know you just because they
know that okay so here's how the YouTube
dispute system works somebody says hey
you've used something that I own in your
video I'm gonna claim monetization of
that video as mine now it doesn't break
down by like minute Mark you know 15
seconds out of a 15 minute video it's
like the whole video now becomes under
the copyright owner and so then you
dispute that and you go ah no it's fair
use it's fair use claim you know wholly
transformative four use factors
submit that and then all they do is they
just go no they just go no we reject
this dispute and then you can submit it
one more time and then if they reject it
again then you have to now file a
lawsuit to maintain your fair use claim
okay so then they know this and so then
then they just they've gotten
sophisticated to it before they weren't
as sophisticated to it and you could go
no dispute and then they'd actually go
oh you know what they do have a fair use
claim well let's just leave it but now
because there's been so much less
monetization in the traditional space
and more monetization and the YouTube
space specifically now they're more
adamant about maintaining monetization
of the stuff that they you know own or
is derivative as they claim on YouTube
and so they just take you through this
process and they know well if we just
click you know just if we just click
reject we just we know that they'll have
to sue us in order to maintain their
fair use claims so we'll just keep doing
that even though we know that it's not
it's not true it is transformative and
it is fair use and anybody who knows
anything about the fair use Doctrine
would agree with me but because we're in
a position to just be able to go dispute
and then you have to file a lawsuit
against us we're just gonna actively
be more aggressive about this because we
can get away with it and that's how most
of this what they call policing of your
copyright works and it's just you know
it's just I don't know why we need to
live like that by the way okay so
why can't they just be like you know
what it is fair use and guess what when
people see that video how much cooler
Are We Now brand awareness we got free
advertising so does this straight up
mean that like we Corridor is not making
any money off this video and probably
won't make any money off this we've made
a little bit off of it but then when
they file their first dispute it goes
into escrow but guess what Nick and I
are on the trim train wait maybe I
shouldn't say it like that
I mean
uh is
a different music right yeah yeah so
Nick and I scrolled through the uh
public archives of YouTube music and we
found one that we think fits fits well
but the problem is that it cuts out both
the song and the audio because the
YouTube editor system is their built-in
system if you want to like trim a
section out of your video but it doesn't
work that well I mean it's great that it
exists but it doesn't work that well so
it can't always distinguish between
audio and music so it's just gonna
replace the section with another song
that's free for us to use
but then we have to well there's two
sections there's 330 to 348 and then
there's 14 seconds to 28 seconds and so
14 seconds is 28 seconds we just had to
trim because it was like that bit where
you're like I'm gonna put the universal
logo above the Earth for real and then
the logo the quarter crew logo hits and
then but then you say it again it's not
as an effective intro which is why we
didn't do it in the first place but it
does get us around that one so then the
second one is wait so did we do that
though yeah it's it's processing right
now oh dang I know I know but we had to
what are we supposed to do just have it
be have you been muted that whole time I
thought we were gonna like re-upload the
video the thing is we tried that on the
last time this happened and then YouTube
rejected the re-upload
because because the re-uploading the the
back door re-uploading feature which by
the way when you're in the YouTube like
partner system and you have like a
direct representative they allow you
it's a very privileged position they
give you a couple like this is exactly
when we would actually need to have it
though yes
is it though and then it takes it also
takes like three days I mean if they
want to incentivize creators making
content that's high quality I would
think so well either way last time we
did it they rejected it because they
said oh this isn't like a good enough
reason to use this back end thing it's
basically only if you accidentally
film somebody who's committed suicide in
a forest and then you need to like
replace that section of your video
that's an extreme example
but that's what I mean like you know and
then they're like oh well uh actually
that's that's a bad example because it
didn't actually happen in that case but
uh anyway well yeah I mean an extreme
example is what I mean they'll allow you
to do it an extreme example but if it's
just like oh Universal claimed your
video we don't care deal with it we got
the trim system cut it out mute it
replace the song you know so they've
become less
um so wait let me get this straight I'm
just learning about this right now so at
the beginning of the video when I
actually State the thesis of the whole
video one of the most important parts
I'm muted no no that is in there that's
in there everything after you as soon as
you go I feel like I'm gonna I feel like
I'm in a horror movie as I'm about to
watch a movie
that's the part when the song comes out
even though it was affected it was deep
pitched it was echoed right there's
Reverb on it I love that shot I love it
too it's a great shot
we gotta send your complaints to
Universal Studios Hollywood California
send it to their services
you are at Universal you're you're
probably some intern lawyer looking at
this send this at the chain our intern
slaved over that VFX shot all right
let's go for that VFX shot I did that
shot
red I'm sure you're gonna have a great
chance convincing the person who's
second year off the bar exam who went to
UCLA for law school who's now working
for whatever big Paul Hastings corporate
firm or Pillsbury they have in downtown
L.A that Universal hires to police their
copyright I'm sure that person's really
going to understand because if they get
it wrong
who above them is going to be like you
know what even though you got this one
wrong for the firm and our big clients
mad at us you did the right thing you
understand fair use law oh well that's
encouraging then great but that's not
how it works I'm just [__] around
yeah that's not how it works
unfortunately even though that person
would be right they can't again it comes
down it's like it doesn't hurt to try
run okay
is this is why we can't let the corpse
get too big guys as I literally say this
on a big Corp Tech platform
but it's true though because it's like
Universal Studios like because they
actively suppress this video
so like the intro goes and then I'm like
I imagine a movie happening well there's
another movie starting and then it
really comes to you saying intro goes
down my desk then you immediately say
I'm gonna put the universal logo in real
in the real world so you you say you say
the same thing Ren I look I know I don't
like it I don't like it I know
it's the reality of it I get it I get it
I'm just trying to cope with this new
this new reaction this new reality yeah
I'm learning about this right now you
guys have had all day to deal with this
new reality I've been well about five
minutes probably to actually no I mean
they originally submitted their claim at
9 14 a.m yesterday morning Pacific time
which was 14 minutes after the video
went live no it was uh 24 hours 15
minutes 24 hours and 15 minutes yeah so
at least I got that first day man
this is this is a company
that is so big it has a city named after
it right getting mad at us right for
something that costs for free
advertising zero money they're getting
mad at us for free advertising well you
know what the sad thing is I think if
they got mad at us it would at least be
more personal it's just like like you're
talking they're not yeah it's just
there's just like a person who works for
a person who works for a person who
works for a person going oh okay flag it
right how can we because think about
okay so I I want to speak to this I want
to speak
the second year Yuppie who's working in
this firm who's like
you know you know Yuppie young urban
professional that's what it means yeah
yeah
but you know a young urban professional
like you know you're suited and booted
you're right you're ready to go in and
fight the good fight for the big Corp so
you go to Paul Hastings right you go up
to that 80th floor in the whatever
building of whatever street and whatever
City you look at this man right here
having so much fun explaining
what comes across your desk you're like
the freaking intern or you check the
corporate account on YouTube and you're
like Discord and someone's like hey
check out this fun Universal video
someone did for our company and
everyone's loving it and then now
it's the job of yours virtually the job
of your firm isn't to expand the fair
use Doctrine in favor of Universal
Studios or like come up with some
Cutting Edge law that case that needs to
be solved before the important appellate
jurisdiction no your job as a lawyer in
this firm is to protect and police
the universal IP rights globally
so what are you going to default to when
you come across that case
you're not gonna you're not gonna take
any risk this is the problem with the
structure of large organizations there's
in Risk taking is not encouraged at all
whatsoever under any circumstances
that's the biggest problem
you're not allowed to do it because if
if you mess up then you're the boss
above you and the boss above them and
then it all you know and and and crap
rolls downhill and gripes roll up that's
how it works but I mean you can't do
that you can't take the risk because
it's it's just too much of a structure
and it's like well who who's even in
charge of it who is even in charge of
the universal IP well Disney has a mouse
what does Universal have a globe they
got everything they literally took a
picture of the globe and then they put
an IP copyright oh should we go it
didn't even come up earthers we should
all copyright them they came up with a
Sans serif fight and they put a Sans
serif font over the Earth that we all
live on and then they claim to come
guess what guess what they left out the
clouds too in the atmosphere right so
they're misrepresenting us as a peoples
exactly they can't even get water right
this came all the way from the giant
minion man I think we have a case the
one that you can see from the 101
Earth versus universal
the people of Earth versus universal
Graphics guy hey
I don't know guys so I don't think it's
worth fighting on this one I think no
exactly that's the thing yeah so then
this has the direct effect
actually cats
DreamWorks boy so so now this has this
has an effect on us now we're like okay
next time we have an idea like this we
know okay don't even go anywhere close
to the theme song and of course music's
always easier to copyright here's the
thing that we had we already have done a
solution to this problem before remember
the the scale of Star Wars video I did
back in the day we had the whole uh Star
Wars tune on kazoos like we had
discussed doing that for this video yeah
brother but we thought it'd be fine like
the the intro you talked about you pitch
shifted it down because we thought it'd
be funny to hear like the really like
off-pitch version of this from it being
in orbit coming over the city and
tearing it up and so funny
we should have just gone the kazoo route
we should have we talked about it I mean
well the thing is so on the corridor
digital it is it is still on
quarterdigital.com you can see the
original version of it right now that's
a really really great look we can here's
the thing we can re-export
and try to do a backdoor submission I'm
just saying in the meantime we did the
trim to get them off our back yeah yeah
so I'm fine to do that I just didn't
want to wait three days and then have
them take all that money that was in
escrow while the video gets you know
another 500 000. wouldn't we still get
it back if we end up like if you win the
dispute but we don't win the dispute
yeah right and then if it if they trim
it it's rigged it's I don't know if I
think the escrow money goes to them if
it's if it's uh
um but anyway yeah that's what we can do
that'll be the solution but either way
it's just interesting and I thought
people might like to hear about how the
intricacies of that that's the exact
reason why we never look at music videos
on vfxrs react even though there are so
many incredible visuals and music videos
that are so worth talking about but we
can't even
rules with the music muted the moment
you show
any music or the moment you can hear any
music is like that that was the easiest
thing to to copyright claim and it's the
most sophisticated now for the automated
AI you know Bots that but the music
doesn't even need to be playing and now
yeah now the music oftentimes doesn't
even be claimed because they're the
music industry is so much more litigious
with respect to this than film and
television
uh that you know it's almost just like
it's unheard of and it became it became
that way obviously in light of such
rampant copyright infringement and
stealing that happened in you know the
early 2000s
um but that happened because they were
charging 20 dollars
for a compact disc of 10 songs in 1997.
20 then
I remember paying 20 doll hairs for a
Tupac CD when I was whatever how
probably too young to own the album but
either way it was 20. it was like your
life sailing it was 21 wow
for ten songs
ridiculous that's ridiculous
it's ridiculous
and the richest country in the world
we've got to have it better it's
ridiculous
I couldn't believe it so anyway they
ripped people off for years well they uh
you know well they all were high on the
hog and taken advantage of every
listener and then you know they got
bitten back by that when the internet
came around and now things are starting
to level out I mean I know Spotify is
not a great deal for the artists on
there so that's unfortunate but maybe
maybe the artist should petition Spotify
to you know raise the I mean they have
been yeah well or they could just band
together and create their own one and
they've done that too have they've done
that too okay I think title was kind of
that your favorite band's t-shirts when
you go to see them in concert yeah dude
yeah yeah I went to go to a little
concert the other night and I bought a
shirt hell yeah that's my contribution
dance hall
Texas dance Texas Hill Country dance
hall an original Slayer
120 year old 125 years
wow where you dance in line like you
dance in you don't move side to side you
move front to back and you move around
in a circle
it's really fun
anyway
does it make you feel like you're a part
of something when everyone's dancing in
the same stuff you know like I was like
this is kind of fun well I mean
yeah oh like I always see in like movies
and stuff they always bust out into
dances on the Dance Floor everyone's
doing the same step and it's yeah
it wasn't that coordinated but it's like
it's like better than there's random
dance yeah there's certain amount types
of dancing that are considered the types
of dance and you should be dancing you
know it's like the waltz yes there's a
waltz yeah there was uh a two-step a
two-step yeah
um is it called line dancing and then
there's line dance and that's the step
that's another one what do you do
there's a place there's a place that I
want to go to uh every summer at the end
of summer they have what's called Old
West Fest and it's this Ranch and they
have like a western town and you can go
there and you pay tickets and there's
events and rides and carnivals and stuff
and one of the things that they do is
inside of the Music Hall they teach you
how to square dance
oh yeah
and they're like
you know I don't know I like salsa
dancing there you go yeah you could do
that I know that I'm sure there's a
place swing dancing I learned how to
swing dance that was fun there you go
I haven't done that in a number of years
did you ever break a collarbone swing
dancing phew
I used to have more collarbone I used to
have a few collarbones now I just have
to so anyways when we do the next
video
we'll be basically we have to just be a
bit more careful and we've we've learned
our lesson here over time we've gotten I
remember the answer is just to not make
any more videos I'm done
thank you for the risk remember it's too
much risk you're saying it's there's
just too much risk involved so I'm just
gonna not make videos now
um
I know
you remember when we used to put Simon
and Garfunkel in the Vlogs yeah we got
away with it too we got away with it as
long as it was less than four seconds
you could get away with it ah good old
Freedom days
ripping off just ripping a song No
putting it in your video
just a couple seconds well it goes to
show you because it was it was allowed
because the platform wasn't taken
seriously
it wasn't I mean I mean I remember
calling people when we were trying to
film so we're making any sink I remember
telling people when we were trying to
film sync and being like so you guys TV
or film or be like YouTube and then
they'd be like so and the rates were
just completely completely astronomical
and different and and I get why they
were like that because there was an
established
modus operandi based upon the reasonable
costs of the industry and people said
okay this is what we can charge for it
and then we started calling people being
like oh yeah we've got like 20 of that
they'd be like uh yeah some of them
would get mad at you be like you know
and it's like well I can't I can't just
come up with more money this is the
amount of money that I have so you don't
have to get mad at me I'm just telling
you what I have and they'd be like
we haven't charged that we wouldn't
charge that if it was Queen Elizabeth
you know or whatever it's like
yeah but some people are just like that
I don't know that much has changed for
the YouTube filmmaking game well but
it's it's more like I think it's more
like the the
the traditional and the New Media
remember you've it used to be called New
Media yeah you're one of them new media
classes in films yes right yeah it's
like new exactly it's just contextualize
the entirety of it as New Media what was
really funny is we took New Media and
they had us making web series that were
structured like exactly like a TV show
right just shorter right and then like
on my weekends I'd come here and shoot
like like YouTube videos with you guys
that was way more New Media than what
was in class right well no one knew what
to do with it they were like is this
television or like how do we
I remember this specifically having a
conversation with Brandon about this
like way back
and then somebody was asking him the
same question about a brand integration
or something and they were like so or
about VGHS and they were like so is this
gonna be like a film or is it gonna be
like television and he's like it's not
gonna be like either of those things
it's gonna be like this
but there wasn't anything to yeah to
construct it against when you're trying
to direct direct it yeah
there was Netflix but it was pre House
of Cards Netflix you know yeah that
would have been around like 2011. it was
when there was still when it was when
Netflix was predominantly in fact in its
entirety
films that were licensed
and it was the best place for that that
was that was back when Netflix's like
online catalog was actually pretty
decent because it was all the stuff that
was out in general yeah and now
everything you know now everything's
original on there everyone was like
cutting the cord and now it costs more
to subscribe to all the different
networks than it did just to have cable
yeah but you can be choosier too of
course of course but if you want all of
it oh yeah I mean it always costs the
most to get all the original days
Netflix had all of it
yeah it's kind of the whole that's fair
but also emerging Industries oftentimes
especially in the tech space you know
they emerge
and they're subsidized through
investment
rather than through charging what it
actually costs to operate that business
I mean this is still the case for Uber
and Lyft people like why is Uber live so
expensive now because what they did was
subsidize through
share price and in capital the amount
that they could charge for a ride so
that everyone got on their platforms and
then once they drove out the taxi
industry they were like okay now we can
finally charge with the guys the taxes
were charging because that's what it
costs
anyways yeah I told you it was going to
be a little salty
I mean that [__] is expensive right it's
very expensive but I feel like there's
been obviously a meeting in the middle
of a lot of the people being willing to
pay for stuff again and also for some of
the traditional pricing to come down
but they'll never be able to pay enough
to see that intro to the universal video
well let's try it back end up actually
no maybe by the time four dollars a
month to see the intro
yeah we give a two-week free trial to
quarterdigital.com
they can't harm us over there anymore
it's safe over there for now because
until they consider it more of a
legitimate player and then we'll have to
you know and they'll be like okay we
need to come to an agreement on
oh gosh when are we gonna need another
lawyer Jake when are you gonna need your
own intern lawyer I I pray that we never
need an in-house lawyer if we need the
news
yeah but I'm like you you have many more
hats I'm like short I'm like hashtag
lawyer I'm like not like yeah same way
like I'm hashtag engineer yeah it's like
if I legitimately have a legal problem I
call my friend from law school Kunal who
specializes in IP law and him and I like
taught each other and traded traded mind
space as we prepared for the bar exam
but then he went out and actually
started his own practice and worked for
a big firm and now has his own practice
and does IP law as a specialty for small
business and I make YouTube videos so
it's like I I it's like I think I know
what the answer is here but if I'm if I
need to be absolutely sure I have to
call him
yeah better call Kunal yeah all right
yeah Jake I'm guessing you've you've
heard about the um the chat GPT lawyer
Scandal right oh no I haven't heard oh
my goodness tell me Griffin there it was
I highly recommend looking up any number
of the wonderful video essays or
podcasts on it I believe uh legal eagle
did a video on it too it's very good
essentially
um there was a case regarding
um it was between Airline uh a passenger
and one of the lawyers yeah you know
what I'm talking about submitted chat
gpg
submitted chat evidence yeah without
verifying any of the the cases
referenced right and it include like
three two of the three cases yes were
entirely
they both looked like total total dances
well yeah dismissed with prejudice so so
yeah so here's how this works wow so
here's how this works
there's there's two companies there's
Lexis Nexus and there's Westlaw I
thought you're gonna say waxes
and then there's Alexis plexus from Long
Beach to Texas
so Alexis Nexus and Westlaw they
basically have the entire Archive of
case law available to you and what
you're supposed to do is if you have a
case like that you look up and you type
in keywords like person on an airplane
you know you type in facts that would be
relevant to your facts and you try to
find a case which just says lands on all
fours we called it meaning that it it's
the same exact situation just for
another person and so if you can find a
case that's in your jurisdiction where
the saint where another person went
through almost the same exact
circumstances you can say this case
doesn't need to be cited because the
court in 1989 you know Johnson versus
Ferguson whatever did this so we don't
need to discuss this motion to for
summary judgment and and but and so
that's what lawyers try to do so they
don't waste the Court's time but
obviously somebody
tried to chat GPT their way through this
rather than using the proper sources
because it takes more time
and they and they obviously didn't
reference it all all it would have taken
was like okay is is Jones versus Smith
an actual case in this jurisdiction and
Westlaw would have been able to tell you
that in like 30 seconds so I don't know
why they didn't do that the main reason
why I've not been able to use chat GPT
for writing any of my videos like I've
tried like I've tried to leverage it not
to actually write my script but to like
Leverage it to like write some scenarios
and stuff like that and it'll write some
stuff and like do some calculations I'm
like oh wow that's crazy and then I
checked the math on it and it's just
completely wrong and it's just made up
it'll just make up facts and make up
references to stuff that just doesn't
exist right why wouldn't it
so I'm just not going to use it yeah the
way I hoped I could it's not trained to
know how to fact check it doesn't that
that's a concept that doesn't even exist
to it it's like it's trained to try to
give information that's relevant back to
you based upon your inquiry it's
literally designed to just give you what
it thinks you want to hear right which
is the last thing that Humanity needs
right now
on part two of this podcast
we tell each other what we want to hear
yeah we have chat gbt tell us that
everything's fine we're perfect and
there's nothing that needs to change
about us no dude she's totally missing
out you're great dude
you don't need to work on yourself this
is the world needs to work on itself
yeah work on itself
anyways yeah dude well hey I don't trust
it it's not that good well I mean just
know know how to use it I think it's the
better the better answer there like just
no like know how to use it know what
it's good for
it's not good for making my videos but
it's great like I literally put in like
the same questions that I've already
answered in previous videos to see what
answers it would give me and it would
give answers that sound right they seem
like they feel like they're right but
they're just not so it's like a
politician
no it legitimately as it it just says
words and they mean absolutely nothing
so it's like a politician it's like they
just go on and on and you're like nobody
even knows at this point maybe we can
throw them in with an AI and just they
can all live on an island together an
island of noise that doesn't make any
sense and they just talk to each other
AI Congress AI Congress
one month Mr Beast challenges
a never-ending AI created Congressional
session totally be the next Mr Beast
video I took over Congress for one month
filibustering
yeah Esther and gets a County
[Laughter]
that's a lobbyist Kickback stop it this
sounds too real okay
100 page section of the next video out
of DC bro oh my God minus the Mr Beast I
know I have nothing against Mr Beast but
that sounds awful no but that's that's
just the fact that that's just only an
extension of the truth I think it says
everything exactly exactly
[Music]
just read facts
the bailiff starts trying to like get
you and you yeah
this this excerpt from the Lincoln
Memoirs is relevant to this
sir this is about the rubber in these
shoes what does this have to do with it
oh my God that'd be funny you want to
talk about the dunk tanks oh do I
let's just say whatever
you use this
out there in the studio right now not
one there are is not one but two dunk
tanks two dunk tanks that will decide
the fate of trick shot Humanity for here
from here to Kingdom Come it's crazy
this morning that was an empty room and
now there are two dunk tanks and a full
trick shot setup surrounding a thousand
gallons of water
with four trick shots to decide
38 ping pong balls also Man versus
machines
stay tuned for that because it's coming
soon more bounces than you've ever seen
before seriously there's one there's a
we we're doing the longest most number
of bounces ping pong trick shot we've
ever done in in the studio in the studio
by Jake the furthest distance uh to
throw a grape into my mouth no I would
win that one so Griffin maybe in the
future we'll do Griffin food trucks if
he threw it at me Griffin why you got it
I had it so epically placed and then
you're like grapes bro
all right I think that's it here anybody
else have any last words
go watch the intro on quarterdigital.com
okay yeah I would honestly say you
should go over there and watch the intro
I mean if you haven't done so I mean I'm
I'm putting a little bit more emphasis
on it's not that big of a deal
and go watch the intro yeah yeah before
we got it we got it on mobile app we got
it on smart TV we got it on desktop oh
what are you waiting for then check it
out yeah all right
everybody thanks for watching
we'll see thanks for listening thanks
for listening ready Ren